all right Alex Trebek shocked us all
yesterday with news that he is battling
Stage four pancreatic cancer this is the
message of the 70 year old or 78 year
old posted yesterday hi everyone I have
some news to share with all of you and
it's in keeping with my longtime policy
of being open and transparent with our
jeopardy fanbase I also wanted to
prevent you from reading or hearing some
overblown or inaccurate reports
regarding my health so therefore I
wanted to be the one to pass along this
information now just like 50,000 other
people in the United States each year
this week I was diagnosed with stage 4
pancreatic cancer now normally the
prognosis for this is not very
encouraging but I'm gonna fight this and
I'm gonna keep working and with the love
and support of my family and friends and
with the help of your prayers also I
plan to beat the low survival rates
statistics for this disease truth told I
have to because under the terms of my
contract I have to host jeopardy for
three more years so help me keep the
faith and we'll win we'll get it done
that's what the well wishes are pouring
in for Alex a fellow game show host Pat
Sajak posted on Twitter the Sajak family
is deeply saddened to hear of Alex
Trebek struggle with cancer our hearts
go to him and his family but there's no
one I know who is stronger and more
determined and I would never bet against
him we and the entire country are
pulling for you Alex yes Stephen Colbert
had this to say on his show last night
everybody loves Alex Trebek so I just
want to say from all of us here the clue
is stay strong Alex and the answer in
the form of a question is what does
everyone watching want you to do Dorota
says Alex is the consistent voice of so
many lives I hopes he makes it through
thanks ER says she's looking good though
four states four if any cancer that
policies have anyone can fight the big
fight no question Alex can
now Michaelis at NewSpring for Alex
Trebek God will carry him through this
what a brave man Maurice is what a great
attitude yeah and he and he brought it
up and I think that the survival rate
for the five-year survival rate I think
it is for Stage four pancreatic cancer
something like three percent right I
think it's a very low thing and it's
interesting when I watched that last
night I had to watch the clip twice
because I was so just taken with Alex
Trebek being Alex Trebek with it with
the cheesy joke at the end of it that I
didn't even really process what he had
just said but he's still being a host
but this wasn't a social media post you
know he's sitting in his house on his I
know you should do this in the studio in
his suit
on the jet like very much I'm still a
host and still gonna do what I do I find
it very interesting the yeah how he
presented I don't think he knows how to
do anything else I'm certain I shouldn't
say that he knows how to do something
else but this is the wonderful food Alex
Trebek is and he is always that sort of
stoic you know down the middle you know
voice of everything that has to do with
sort of truth and reason and with the
cheesy joke on the side and that's just
who you know Alex Trebek is and then as
Stephen Colbert said that's why
everybody loves Alex Trebek there is
nobody it doesn't matter what you love
them as far as entertainment or what
movies you go to or what music you
listen to everybody agrees that Alex
Trebek is the real deal yeah yeah and
Nicole says I have a good friend who
survived States for pancreatic cancer
yeah yeah there's definitely people that
I survived it so it looked Alex
[Music]